[Musique]
les chantiers sont la marque de commerce
du président macky sall comme on le voit
dans cette publicité
aéroports autoroutes 2000 km de pistes
rurales 13 fond le projet de la cité des
affaires une vaste cité des affaires et
un très rapide
le premier en afrique de l'ouest bien la
république et le confort il ya également
la sécurité oblige les opposants c'est
que tous ces chantiers n'ont pas fait
baisser un taux de chômage très élevé
plus de 45 % de ces jeunes pour ceux qui
ont une formation ne peut pas accéder au
marché de l'emploi
et ça crée une situation de ma vie
extraordinaire dont une bonne partie
tente l'aventuré en prenant les pirogues
de fortune pour aller en europe ou le
désert à 44 ans ousmane seul coup il le
plus jeune candidat dans cette
présidentielle
ancien inspecteur des impôts et lanceurs
d'alert il a été congédié pour avoir
dénoncé la corruption
il accuse aussi macky sall de permettre
aux entreprises étrangères de piller les
ressources comme le pétrole vous voyez
des marchés où les chinois viennent avec
des oeufs
il n'a même que les chinois vous avez
des trucs qui n'a manqué d'être des
indiens qui n'a manqué d n'diaye et la
jeunesse sénégalaise elle a appris le
chômage ya pas que des chinois il ya une
partie de chez moi qu'ils ont avec eux
la technologie ati traoré défend le
bilan du président sortant qui aurait
selon lui réduit la pauvreté en faisant
grimper la croissance économique de 2 à
6% faut disent les opposants car seuls
les biens nantis et les multinationales
profitent de cette croissance
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de 45% de la
population qui est en deçà de ce seuil
de pauvreté qui ne peut pas se soigner
correctement
au sénégal les gens meurent dans les
hôpitaux ousmane somme qu'on veut créer
des emplois en nationalisant des marchés
où ce qu'on voit que la france comprenne
et nous voudrons que le monde entier de
comprendre c'est que les choses doivent
changer que les relations doivent être
plus équilibré que
le partenariat doit être gagnant gagnant
[Applaudissements]
un discours qui plaît aux jeunes nés qui
dérange des éléments de l'agenda
national ont été envoyés à mon domicile
familial pour intimider ma propre ma
propre mère macky sall il a adopté cette
mauvaise habitude d'intimider ses
opposants d'intimider d'emprisonner
d'exilés en utilisant tous les leviers
dont il dispose
on n'est pas un état policier je suis
désolé parce que le sénégal est reconnu
par sa démocratie madame langlois se
plaisant macky sall a mis tout un
dispositif pour former ces élections des
opposants soupçonnent le président de
prendre les moyens pour l'emporter dès
le premier tour
car les candidats les plus populaires
ont été écartés pour moi pouvons dire
que nous allons fabriquer des élections
en 3d résultat c'est pas possible dans
d'autres pays peut-être mais au sénégal
l'opinion ne pourra plus se laisser
faire
les eaux les élections se font
régulièrement et le meilleur gagne des
sénégalais s'inquiète car il est rare
qu'une élection équitable à cinq
candidats dont une victoire au premier
tour ici sophie langlois radio canada
montréal